This video is sponsored by Oculus rift.
Hey guys,
Helen here.
Full disclosure,
Oculus came to us and said they were
fans of our work,
which was one really flattering and two
really awesome because you know jared
and I love that new tech.
Anyway,
they asked if we had anything smart to
say about Vr and Vr has been in the
media a ton lately from the rise of
[inaudible] and Nma,
like sword art online and overlord,
who smash hits like ready player one.
We got pretty excited.
Even rick and morty uses vr for one of
our favorite gags.
Roy,
you're not bad.
Morty.
Kind of wasted your thirties though with
that whole birdwatching faith.
Where's my wife?
You were just playing a game.
It's called Roy snap out of it.
Now I know we hear it.
Wise crack can get pretty tech,
the phobic,
but we wanted to try out this thing
called optimism.
If science fiction is any indication the
mass exodus to virtual worlds is
inevitable,
but instead of jumping on the prophecy
train,
we're going to talk about some of the
philosophical ramifications of the art
technology and how it can revolutionize
storytelling and perspective,
and while we could view Vr as just
another step in technology like the jump
from radio to film,
there seems to be something more to it.
That's something we think is a
philosophical concept called Kuala
welcome to this wise crack addition on
the philosophy of Vr and yeah.
Wow.
No spoilers ahead,
but before we get into quality out,
we should say something about
storytelling.
There are a million reasons why someone
would tell a story the muses told you to
or the absence told you to or the
amphetamines told you to,
but at the core of every story is a
single ask to inhabit a character's
perspective.
Roald Dahl,
author of everyone's favorite book about
a greedy CEO exploiting immigrant labor,
said it best in Matilda.
The books transported Matilda into new
worlds and introduced her to amazing
people who live exciting lives.
She went on olden days,
sailing ships with Joseph Conrad.
She went to Africa with Ernest Hemingway
and to India with Rudy kipling.
She traveled all over the world while
sitting in her little room in an English
village by allowing us to inhabit the
mind and body of its characters.
Storytelling can challenge our
perspective and change our views,
but as amazing as these stories are
traditional mediums like literature and
film,
stop a little short when it comes to
inhabiting the perspective,
whether we're living vicariously through
Frodo,
delivering the ring to more door or the
dude just trying to get his rug back on
your feet and lift.
We're always reminded of the space
between us and the characters.
John Gardner,
in his book,
the art of fiction calls this concept
psychic distance or basically how deep
we are in the character's head.
It's the difference between reading the
sentence.
He walked to the store and he ambled to
the store.
Wild thoughts racing on his mind.
The latter example brings us closer,
but regardless of how the story is told,
we can never collapsed the psychic
distance to zero while staring at the
pages.
In a book or a TV on the wall will
inevitably notice that these thoughts
and aren't our own,
and as it turns out,
there's a good philosophical reason why
this distance can never be fully closed.
This concept called Kuala in philosophy.
Quality is the idea that mental states
like perception,
sensations,
thoughts,
and emotions all have a certain
subjective feeling to them.
When you sip wine or stare at the
sunset,
these experiences are all unique to you
in that moment.
The key word here is unique.
Your friend could do all the same things
and still have a different experience
and you wouldn't ever be able to really
explain this difference either.
As philosopher Thomas Nagel explained in
his paper,
what is it like to be a bat?
We could know everything there is to
know about that,
but that doesn't translate to knowing
what it's like to be flapping about and
navigating via sound.
And that's the weird thing about this
whole quality of debate.
There's an explanatory gap between
knowledge and experience.
One that has some pretty big
philosophical and everyday consequences
for philosophers who believed that the
world can be explained by laws and
science.
They now have to explain this new type
of knowledge seemingly unrelated to
facts and for everyone else,
we're doomed to tell funny stories about
things that happened,
failed,
and then fall back on the old.
You should have been their defense.
The big takeaway is that this gap
between knowledge and experience is real
and no matter how many words we write on
a page or how many flashing images we
have on the screen,
we can never bridge that well,
maybe not never.
So what does that have to do with Vr?
Well,
the reason why Vr is so groundbreaking,
or in Marty's case mind bending morty,
you're rick,
is because vr gets us infinitely closer
to bridging that gap.
Unlike reading a book or watching TV,
Vr is an embodied experience.
You're right there in the story
sometimes inhabiting the body of your
favorite characters.
This not only drastically reduces the
psychic distance gardener talked about,
but it also deals with the pesky quality
of problem.
Can't adequately explain how great your
vacation was to your friends.
Well,
let them experience it themselves by
throwing a headset on them and we can't
emphasize this enough.
The difference between knowing something
and experiencing something is huge.
It's why you can feel somewhat safe
watching the ring on tv,
but grab your pants,
the threesixty experience combined vr
with haptic feedback and full body
motion tracking and you can easily be
fully immersed for hours.
Now,
before we move on,
as I mentioned,
this video is sponsored by Oculus rift.
If you're looking to dive into new
worlds,
it's available for only three 99.
If you've ever wanted to be a rage
filled green giant or a sas field,
trash panda,
you can save the world and marvel
powers,
United Vr,
or if you've ever wanted to get your
tabletop strategy game on and don't have
hundreds of hours to build Internet
landscapes.
There's brass tactics which looks so
cool.
There's also the story driven Lone Echo
and the robotic mayhem of echo arena and
there are all exclusive.
If you want to see me try out the oculus
rift for myself,
stick around till the end of the video.
Now,
back to the philosophy.
Okay,
I know what you're thinking,
Helen.
Even a vr allows you to sit behind the
eyes of your favorite characters.
That experience is still subjective and
unique to you.
Multiple friends could watch the same
three 60 film or play the same vr game
and they would still all have different
experiences.
We haven't fully bridged quality as
explanatory gap and while that's
definitely true,
vr actively tries to combat this.
At comic con,
we caught up with Ian Forester,
CEO of Vr playhouse,
who's team had just created a vr
experience for the show.
Mr Mercedes,
when asked about the explanatory gap,
he told us how good vr tries to bridge
it and trying to create a fully
immersive experience.
There needs to be a palate cleanser
almost.
It's what we refer to as onboarding.
You are you.
We get that,
but now you're going to assume a
different role and different
circumstance.
Onboarding is essentially a tutorial
section in a vr experience.
It tells you about the character you're
inhabiting and how to interact with the
vr world around you.
In doing so,
onboarding combats the explanatory gap
by asking you to forget well yourself.
It's kind of like the suspension of
disbelief in theater,
except instead of asking us to forget
the stage,
the curtains,
the not very convincing set,
it's asking us to forget our actual
selves,
so how effectively can vr bridge quality
as explanatory gap stripping us of us
and making us assume a new identity?
The short answer is pretty damn well.
Recent studies have shown some science
fiction level results.
For example,
in one study when white subjects
inhabited a black virtual Avatar,
they actually exhibit noticeably less
racial bias than those who didn't.
In another experiment when adults were
placed in a virtual child's body,
they started exhibiting more childlike
behaviors.
According to philosopher Frederick David
Moan,
our sense of self is deeply entangled
with the body we inhabit,
partly because our body is the only
thing we both perceived and perceive
width.
It's a bit like acting.
We notice our costume and we start
adjusting our attitudes accordingly,
and while we might not fully be able to
know 100 percent was like to be another
person,
vr can get as close.
It's exactly vrs ability to almost
inhabit other subjective experiences
that makes it right for new therapy
techniques.
Freud,
me,
for example,
puts patients in a motion capture suit
and a Vr headset.
When the program starts,
patients find themselves in a vr replica
of their own body moving exactly in sync
with their real life body.
They then tell a silent Dr Freud across
the room about their problems.
After they're done,
users then inhabit the body of Dr Freud
and hear their own problems from this
outside perspective before offering
solutions to themselves.
The results are pretty crazy with
patients reportedly experiencing greatly
improved moves after undergoing the art
therapy,
all because patients were able to step
outside of their own bodies,
and it's not just virtual chitchats with
Freud that are seeing great results in
Vr therapy.
Things like exposure therapy or helping
patients conquer certain fears and
phobias by facing them have huge success
rates in Vr.
In one study,
vr exposure therapy had over a 90
percent success rate in treating the
fear of flying,
which seems better than the popular pop,
a Xanax and downed a bottle of wine
approach,
but buckling patients into a new
perspective,
it gives them a safer way to face their
fears.
Well,
some might consider vr a form of escape
from reality.
We can also see how it can give us an
entirely new perspective on the very not
fictional world.
So what does the future of Vr hold?
Well,
we may be a long way off from a full
ready player one,
but with computers getting stronger and
wireless headsets coming out,
we're making progress.
And while we as a society sometimes
indulgent fearmongering about future
tech from skynet Matrix,
vr has the potential to make a really
positive impact.
Did you know there are guys who actually
lug heavy threesixty cameras around
mountain trails and just so people who
can't hike them can still experience
them and yeah,
we might be scared of creating some
ready player.
One escape is nightmare,
but a social philosopher,
Ernst Bloch argued daydreaming and
escapism actually can positively
influence society by exploring the
possibilities of how things could be
different.
We engaged in an immature but honest
substitute for revolution,
one that can bring about machine to
change the society today,
right?
I want to check out this oculus rift and
see what it's all about.
I also just want to say that without
sponsors like oculus rift,
many of our episodes wouldn't even be
possible,
so thanks guys.
Now where's my headset out?
Let's do this.
Here we go.
Alright,
here we go.
Robo recall
hook your regularly scheduled
programming incoming.
That was awesome.
Click the link in the description below
to get more info on how you can get an
oculus rift of
your own.